[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
welcome walter welcome to you too thank
you
what are we doing now well we're
discussing some questions again
and uh i like the topics that the people
ask
so like last time we had a nice bible
study on romans 3
let's see what this brings up let's see
where we go
let's pray our heavenly father thank you
again for bringing us together
we again ask you to bless our minds with
the enlightenment of the holy spirit
and then also our viewers in jesus name
amen
as we said last time questions
are very very important
you know when i was at university
students would sometimes be embarrassed
to ask questions
because you know some people would mock
and tease them etc but i was always of
the opinion there is no such thing as an
irrelevant question
a question is something that requires an
answer
yeah and uh may the lord help us
according to the best of our abilities
to
provide answers when there are problems
and if we do not know then we must say
we don't know is there someone who can
help us exactly i think
i've somewhere heard that the only
stupid question
is the question not asked correct that's
a very good way of putting it
so here is a question that has been
presented to us there's a verse in the
bible that says
when jesus died he went to preach to
those who
died in the time of nara what does this
mean you see in the creeds
of the churches we have the statement he
ascended into hell
but of course this word in in the bible
hell
is actually grave yeah
so if you have a different concept of
hell as a place
where those who do not die in a right
standing with god go to after death
then you can develop this confusion and
there are some verses
which seem to indicate that
that is the way you should interpret it
so the verses they're referring to here
are in first peter chapter 3 let's just
read what they say here
for christ also has once suffered for
sins
the just for the unjust that you have
the plan of salvation again
that he might bring us to god being put
to death in the flesh
but quickened by the spirit so this
is just the statement that christ died
for our sins
that he rose again from the dead
by which also he went and preached
unto the spirits in prison
which sometime were disobedient
when once the long-suffering of god
waited in the days of
noah while the ark was a preparing
wherein
few that his eight souls were saved
now let's analyze this carefully
he's referring to the spirit
he was quickened by the spirit he rose
from the dead
right now by the same spirit
he also preached unto the spirits that
are
in prison now the bible calls the grave
a prison so these people are now dead
and the holy spirit was once
active amongst those people as well
which sometime were disobedient when
once the long-suffering of god waited in
the days of
noah while the ark was a preparing
now the question here is
did god by his holy spirit
work in those children of disobedience
in the times of noah yes or no yes
absolutely
so let's read this in this fashion
so this spirit this holy spirit
was also active in the time of noah
these people are now dead but in the
time of noah
the spirit worked with them as he is
working
with us today while the ark was
preparing were in
few that is eight souls were saved by
water
so basically all this verse says is that
the same holy spirit
that is working in us worked in days
past
with those that are now dead but that
lived in the time of noah
it's not saying that jesus went to
a place called hell and spoke to those
people
over there that's really quite simple
yeah if you know that the word hardest
means grave then this confusion would
not exist
so basically what is brought about the
concu confusion
the doctrines of the churches
and where did they get that doctrine
from
from rome
how do we justify our belief that man
cannot forgive sins
in light of john 20 21-23
well basically these verses say
whosoever sins ye remit
they are remitted unto them and
whosoever sins ye retain
they are retained so let's just go to
some
bible verses to get some clarity here
luke chapter 5 verse 21 says and the
scribes and the pharisees began to
reason saying who is this
which speaketh blasphemies who can
forgive
sins but god alone
in other words it was common knowledge
in those days that god alone
forgives sins yes and because jesus had
said
to that person that he healed your sins
are forgiven
this was considered blasphemy so
the the bottom line is only god can
forgive
sins so in the light of that we have to
interpret
the other verses
paul also addresses this issue
and he says do you not know that we will
judge
angels is it therefore not possible for
you to judge the simple things that
happen in a church
so basically what jesus was saying
that if the church judges a simple
matter
let's say a man is caught in adultery
then the church has the right to judge
the matter
and to say this individual is placed
under sinjar
because he has transgressed the law
and if he doesn't make this right and if
he doesn't
apologize and come back into harmony
with the principles of god
he stays excluded let's say he moved in
with someone
while he was married then he's living in
transgression
and the church knowing the standards
says
excuse me you are under censure and then
if he makes matters right and he repents
then the church will take him back so
god will acknowledge that cenga
as a right act it doesn't mean that the
sin of that individual is forgiven by
the church
it means that they have the capacity to
judge an issue
and to make recommendations based on the
principles of god's law that's all it
means
please establish a strong argument for
the doctrine of investigative judgment
from the bible only
there are many people that say
that the adventists have it wrong when
they talk about an investigative
judgment
the words investigative judgment do not
appear in the bible
but that doesn't mean that the principle
of an investigative judgment
does not appear in the bible any
any court of law has various
phases of activity
when a case is brought before a judge
there is first a discussion as to
whether the person is guilty or not
in other words there's an investigation
yes right
you might not call it that but that is
actually what takes place
that's what a court case is all about
and once that
investigation has been carried out
then there can come a pronouncement of
judgment
and after the pronouncement of judgment
there is an execution of that judgment
in other words you have an investigation
you have a pronouncement
and you have a execution
of judgment executive judgment
those are the phases of judgment
so what about the bible does it speak
about these issues in any way so let's
look at it carefully
firstly there is a judgment in the bible
we know that you can find it in the new
testament you can find it in the old
testament
and it's very consistent
so there is a judgment let's read a few
verses
ecclesiastes 12 13 let us hear the
conclusion of the whole matter
fear god and keep his commandments for
this
is the whole duty of man
for god shall bring every work into
judgment with every secret thing
whether it be good or whether it will be
evil so there will be a judgment
right definitely and who is the one who
is doing the judging here
god god secondly
the judgment is for all men romans 14
verse 10
but why dost thou judge thy brother
or why dost thou set at not thy brother
for we shall all stand before the
judgment seat
of christ all judgment has
been handed over to christ
in a very interesting sense christ
himself
is also being judged yeah because there
was a war
in heaven and satan accused the
government of god
in other words he accused jesus christ
of
unfair practice by eliminating him from
heaven
and yet providing redemption for adam
and eve
yes so christ and his righteousness
his correct doing are also in a sense
being judged
now the third point is the judgment will
be for the righteous
and the wicked ecclesiastes 3 17
i said in my heart god shall judge the
righteous
and the wicked for there is a time
therefore
every purpose and for every work
so there will be the righteous and there
will be
the wicked jesus refers to the sheep
and the goats the good fish and the bad
fish
that there will be a separation
so we have established there is a
judgment
the judgment will be for the just and
for the wicked nobody is excluded we
will all stand before
the judgment seat of christ and paul
makes it quite clear
you cannot as a human determine the
motives of the heart
leave that to god to god leave that to
god
now the fourth point is there will be an
investigation
for the books of record or to be opened
right yes daniel chapter 7 verse 10.
well you know we can read it here but we
can also go to the bible
great i always like going to the bible
directly
and we can look at the book of daniel
and we can go to daniel chapter
and in interesting in chapter 7
he describes these creatures
these beasts that arise these kingdoms
that will arise
and from verse 9 we have a new paragraph
and it says i beheld till thrones were
cast
down and the ancient of days did sit
whose garment was white as snow and the
hair of his head
like the pure wool
his throne was like the fiery flame and
his wheels as
burning fire a fiery stream
issued and came forth from before him
thousand thousands ministered unto him
and
ten thousand times thousands
stood before him the judgment was set
and the books were opened now martin
where does the scene take place
in heaven it takes place in heaven and
books are being opened
now what books are these there are
various books mentioned in the bible
there is the book of life yes
and by the way who is written in the
book of life
every person every single person is
written in the book of life
so christ died for all but can you
your name be removed from the book of
life
unfortunately yes unfortunately yes and
that will be based upon what
your acts your deeds and your decisions
yes
right
i beheld then because of the voice of
the great
words which the horns spake i beheld
even till the beast was slain and the
body destroyed and given to the burning
flame
so while the scene is taking place in
heaven
there are great words being spoken down
here
and he looks through the stream of time
even to the point where that entity will
be destroyed
yes so basically
daniel 7 tells us about a judgment scene
which
takes place in heaven and books are
being opened
now what would be the purpose of opening
books
to glance at it and look at it read it
see what's going on in there and to
investigate
whether someone is in the book of life
or
not in the book of life are there deeds
of such a nature
that they will not be scratched out of
the book of life
did they have faith etc
so luke chapter 21 verse 36 says watch
ye therefore and pray
always that you might be accounted
worthy to escape all these things that
shall come to pass
and to stand before the son of man
so in other words the time will come
when you will stand before the son of
man and give an account
but the books have already been studied
in heaven prior to that prior to that
okay the fifth point is
there will be a pronouncement of the
verdict so there must be an
investigation
the books were opened and
take care of how you live your life
because eventually you will
confront christ himself
and you will be confronted with whatever
has been determined from that
investigation and then there will be a
pronouncement of
of a verdict and some people will say
when they hear the verdict but lord lord
didn't we
do all these wonderful things in your
name in your name and he will say
depart from me and then there's an
interesting word there
ye that practice anno miya
against the law of god
and we must not forget that so
revelation 22
11 says he that is unjust let him be
unjust still and he which is filthy
let him be filthy still and he that is
righteous let him be righteous
still and he that is holy let him be
holy
still in other words when that
investigation
has come to an end for all of humanity
then god initiates the cutoff point
and he says from now on those
that were unjust let them be unjustl
those that were righteous let them be
righteous still
and if you are holy you will remain holy
if you are unholy you will remain unholy
in other words probation is closed
so that is a final close
to the entire judgment scene
revelation 22 verse 12 says and behold
i come quickly and my reward is
with me to give every man
according as his work shall be
so here's my question he says he's
coming quickly and he brings his reward
with them what is that reward
well it will be either eternal life or
eternal judgment
okay that's the it's the verdict of the
of the whole
investigative judgment okay so this
decision
must take place when prior yes
or after he's coming before otherwise he
cannot bring his reward with can't come
with the reward so obviously there is
this
investigation and the pronouncement of
the close of probation
and then when he comes his reward
will be with him now in the resurrection
is there more than one resurrection yes
yes
you have the resurrection of the just
and the rest of the dead did not wake up
right that says the bible
and they remained in the graves how long
thousands a thousand years
so only if you are part of the first
resurrection
are you part of the resurrection of the
redeemed
if you're part of the second
resurrection then that is very bad news
it means that you are eternally lost
the sixth point is there will be an
executive judgment so we've gone through
the phases
revelation 20 verse 11 says and i saw
a great white throne and him that sat on
it
from whose faith the earth and the
heavens fled away
and there was found no place for them
and whosoever was not found written in
the book of life was cast into the lake
of fire
now this is after the millennium
this is the second resurrection yes
so here you have this great white throne
the dead
the unrighteous dead are raised and they
face
the consequences of their actions
and if they were not found written in
the book they were cast
into the lake of fire
now verse 14 had defined that lake of
fire
and if we read verse 14 it says
and death and hell were cast into the
lake of
fire this is the second death
yes so that is the final destruction of
the wicked
the second death from which there is no
resurrection the seventh point we would
like to
mention is there will be a clearing
of the righteous you have to be cleared
of your transgression because all have
sinned and fall short of the glory of
god
so hebrews 12 23 tells us
to the general assembly and church of
the firstborn
which are written in heaven and to god
the judge of
all and to the spirits of just men
made perfect
so he's referring to the church and he
said here
are individuals that are no longer
unrighteous but have now
been declared righteous now we have to
be very careful how we study this
so point eight that we want to mention
is
there will be an accounting worthy
of the righteous before the second
coming of christ it must take place
before
the second coming of christ because
otherwise there couldn't be a reward
and a resurrection of the just because
they must have been
declared just right otherwise you would
have had to
bring up all and then declare it and the
rest would have corrected
and that's not how it happens there's
only a resurrection of those that died
in christ
and they are accounted worthy it's
important that we
study this carefully now luke chapter
20 from verse 34 onward says and jesus
answering said unto them the children of
this world
marry and are given in marriage
but they which shall be accounted worthy
to obtain that world and the
resurrection from the dead
neither marry nor are given in marriage
now we're not using this verse to talk
about marriage and what marriage will be
like in heaven
it's simply about being accounted
worthy to obtain that world and the
resurrection from the dead
so they must have been accounted worthy
yes now what does that mean
that means it must have been a study to
see if you are worthy
yes there must have been an
investigation to see if you
are worthy so
this accounting worthy verse 36 says
watch ye therefore and pray always
that you may be accounted worthy
to escape all these things that shall
come to pass
and to stand before the son of man
in the investigation you have to be
accounted worthy otherwise you cannot be
part
of the first resurrection correct so
let's look at this word
accounted worthy what is it
in the bible the word is kataksiyu
and this is the concordance strong's to
deem
entirely deserving to count
worthy now according to molten and
milligan
this greek word does not mean to make
worthy but to count worthy
and here is again a difference between
catholicism
and protestantism catholicism teaches
that you
are made worthy protestant teaching
is that you are countered worthy
in other words it is the imputed
and important righteousness which you
appropriate by faith
which makes you countered as
worthy so the gift
is always a gift from the giver
and not something that you eventually
attain
it is an imputed and imparted
alien righteousness so that no
man can boast
so i hope that this answers the question
of whether there is an investigation
or whether there is not an investigation
and it hopefully also answers that that
investigative judgment
is prior to jesus second coming it has
to be
otherwise there could be no resurrection
of the just and an ignoring of the
unjust
correct is satan's personification of
jesus second coming happening before
or after the close of probation is there
any point
in deceiving people after the close of
probation
no no so any form of deception that
takes place
whereby you induce people
to follow a particular teaching
must take place prior to the close of
probation
so satan's masquerading as the angel of
light will take
place before the crows close off
probation
and he will use
words of christ himself to lead people
away from the truth and the law of god
and bring across his point of view
and people will be deceived by it but
those who know their bible
will know that jesus christ will not
come in this way
number one the bible tells us that the
righteous will meet him in the sky in
other words he will not touch this
earth with his feet whereas this
imposter will be
visible in city to city walking upon the
ground
and his words will be contrary to the
word of god
he will for example say that the sabbath
has been changed
but there's no statement in the bible
that that is the case
and it not to be taken lightly
you will do it in a way that will be
very hard
to distinguish you'll have to be
grounded and anchored in the word
absolutely he's a master of deception
and he was a liar from the beginning
what does it mean to walk in the spirit
galatians 5
16 well in colossians 1
27 we read to whom god would make
known what is the riches of the glory of
this
mystery among the gentiles which is
christ in you the hope of glory
in other words what does it mean to walk
in the spirit
to have christ it means to have christ
in you
and who works the good works
when christ is in you him it is christ
working in you that is the hope of glory
now can christ be in disharmony with his
own teachings no
so in other words what is the criterium
to determine whether someone is walking
in the spirit or not
if he's keeping the law and walking
according to the bible
walking according to the bible and doing
what the bible says because that is what
christ
came to do he was the embodiment of the
law
so in other words if you want to know
whether somebody is justified
or not and whether he's walking in the
spirit
you have to ask yourself like james says
if the works are not in accordance
with the spirit then you are not
walking according to the spirit and
the bible makes it quite clear in acts
chapter 5
that god gives his holy spirit to them
that
obey him correct so there you have the
criteria
as to whether someone is walking in the
spirit
or not by the fruits you will know them
obedience without
love and faith is also worthless it's
totally worthless
how do you didn't you once say it's not
uh good people that go to heaven
it's obedient people that go to heaven
and people don't like that statement
because it sounds like a legalistic
yes but did jesus say that if you love
me
keep my commandments is that obedience
that's obedience so do you show love by
obedience
yeah the other thing of course is what
is your
motive yes for keeping the commandments
is it fear fear will not get you to
heaven
so what is the motive is is it love
if you love me keep my commandments
that means you must have so studied
yourself into this
into this argument that
you eventually see it from the point of
view that god sees exactly
you must not have the faith alone in
jesus you must have the faith
of jesus and he says
i have kept my father's commandments yes
therefore when you study the
commandments and you internalize them
and you see that they are perfectly
logical and
absolutely necessary for peace and
harmony and love to flourish
then it's no longer a command
but it is an act of love to keep them
amen there is a 40-year period between
the plagues and the exodus
and the claiming of the promised land
during that period the israelites were a
terribly stiff next people who defied
the lord
who was among them can you please
address the antitype
of that period
a that's a very interesting question now
i actually did a whole series on that
once
it's called total transformation
perhaps you can put a link in i will to
that
uh let's put it mildly
whatever the israelites did when they
were the stiff-necked
people we've improved upon it yes
god's people today are no less
stiff-necked than were the israelites of
all no matter what aspect you touch
take diet for example
they were craving the flesh pots of
egypt modern israel god's people today
crave the flesh pots of egypt
is that nice word murmuring murmuring
idolatry we have so many idols
they just take a different form
and yes i think people should perhaps
take some time and look at that series
what's important for me on that series
is
it's the story of the bible
if you have all this knowledge
but there's no transformation yes and
it's worth nothing
it's not enough to have a head knowledge
of the plan of salvation
you can quote every single verse in the
bible the devil is very good at quoting
verses
in the bible but if it's not applied to
the heart
then it's not the bomb of gilead correct
so yes there is a stiff neck people
living today yeah there's an anti-type
is alive and well
exactly and who are we to say
well they are the stiff-necked ones
there are many many aspects in our lives
where we
qualify perfectly as a stiff-necked
people
correct yes
please would you talk about the second
great exodus and how close do you think
we are to it
well what was the first exorcist all
about
it was a salvation
from physical slavery
bondage what is the second great exodus
it is a salvation from spiritual bondage
bondage to sin so there is an exodus
which takes place
in your personal life when you accept
the gospel
then there is an exodus from the bondage
of
sin into the salvation
which is offered to you by christ
that takes place on an individual level
but then you also have a corporate
salvation
just as the israelites as a nation
were taken out of the bondage of egypt
which served as a time for
god's people at the end to come
out of that bondage
come out of babylon in other words the
bondage of sin
babylon is confusion and
syncretism and mixing truth and error
god says come out of that mess because
it has become a house of demons
a house of every unclean and detestable
bird there's a
false holy spirit leading you
into rebellion against god's law rather
in than into harmony with god's law
and come out so that you do not partake
of her plagues and do not come into
judgment and judgment has a basis as we
discussed in our previous what's up
which is the law
yes transgression of it come out of
my people and in that final call
just before the close of probation we
as a people of god are basically
at baal pior
on that great moment
when that final apostasy takes place
even within the church
and there is a separation a shaking
from even within the church
and after that they went into canaan
so god's people will go into the
heavenly canaan
once that probation has closed the
plagues have fallen
and christ comes to fetch his people
so so there's an individual and
a corporate exodus
and how close do you think we are to it
even at the door didn't we have one like
that amen
and then there was a statement that i
thought was very beautiful that we can
maybe just discuss a little bit
righteousness by faith is the headline
and this person said my wife and i have
been reading through the great
controversy lately and i
just realized that there is a constant
threat of righteousness by faith
that you can follow all the way from
adam eve cain and abel
through the dark ages the reformation
all the way down to today
this has been the most viciously
attacked subject
by satan throughout every age
absolutely spot on
righteousness by faith is contrary
to the human nature
we do not want to acknowledge
our helpless state
we want to be able to contribute
to our salvation but a dead person as we
said cannot contribute anything
righteousness by faith is the third
angel's message in verity
so yes it says do not accept the mark of
the beast do not conform
to his law which is contrary to god's
law
because righteousness is made manifest
by obedience to god's commandments right
yes not as a means to salvation but as a
consequence of salvation
all our righteousness is filthy rags
and this beautiful truth that the god of
heaven
should condescend to come and take the
place
of a sinner dead in transgression
take the stripes that should be on me
unto himself pay that price
and then offer that eternal life
back to me on the condition
of righteousness by faith
and faith alone not by works
so that i cannot boast in anything but
the righteousness of christ
that's the beauty of salvation that's
the biblical message
and that is a message that most of the
world
does not want to accept and to my horror
the protestant world has compromised
that
doctrine in the joint declaration of
justification
because now as you know it reads
that we are saved by grace alone and not
faith alone and by christ's saving
works and not by his atoning blood and
that protestants
should put their pen to paper is
mind-boggling
to me righteousness by faith
does not negate like we've said before
keeping the law correct isn't there in
hebrews
the whole story about abraham that kept
his faith but also the bible tells us
that
abraham kept the commandments okay let's
go to that verse i think it's
genesis chapter 26
and it's verse 5
where it says because that abraham
obeyed my voice
and kept my charge and my commandments
my statutes
and my laws say if abraham
was saved by faith alone then what
commandments and statutes and laws did
he keep here
so his faith was made perfect
by works as jude says and if we go to
the book of hebrews
and just before we go there i just want
to mention
this is before sinai
oh yes so it's not the same law that
moses gave to the israelites
no no it i'm sorry it is the same law
but it means it's been applicable before
it was spoken correct we know that the
law was
there before because when he took them
out of egypt he said i will test them
whether they will
walk according to my law or not and
the manna fell as you know
in such a way that the sabbath was made
prominent again
before yes they came to mount
sinai now when we go to the book of
hebrews
and in the first chapter it tells us
exactly
who jesus is it's a it's a beautiful
chapter
it's probably one of the most
marvelously
written chapters in the bible
it has so much depth i think
in a future episode
maybe you can work us through of the
book of hebrews a little bit maybe we
should
go through the book of hebrews but the
first chapter tells us who jesus
is the first chapter tells us that he is
the creator
that he is
he is the exalted son of god
to which of the angels in verse 13 said
he at any time
sit on my right hand until i make thine
enemies thy
footstool are they not all ministering
spirits sent forth to minister for them
who shall be heirs to of salvation
the exalted nature of the son of god
is brought out in chapter one we won't
go into the details
at this moment and if we go to chapter 2
then it tells us about this great
salvation
verse 3 says how shall we escape
if we neglect so great salvation
salvation is is the study of eternity
which at the first began to be spoken by
the lord and was confirmed unto us
by them that heard him that's the
disciples
they confirmed it and if you go to verse
for it became him for whom are all
things and
by whom are all things
in bringing many sons unto glory
to make the captain of their salvation
perfect through
suffering so jesus went through
suffering because of us
verse 14 says for as much then as the
children are partakers of flesh and
blood
he also himself likewise took
part of the same that through death he
might destroy him that had the power of
death
that is the devil
and then in verse 15 he brings us to
abraham and he says for verily he took
not on him the nature of angels
but he took on him the seed of abraham
in other words he became fully human to
identify himself with
humanity and paid the price
for humanity now it's a sad thing that
many
modern translations pervert verse 16
and will say surely it is not angels
that he helps
but this translation here in the king
james is
so spot on for verily it took
not on him the nature of angels
but he took on him the seed of abraham
and then when we go to the great chapter
of faith which is chapter 11.
and we've spoken about this many many
times and i've spoken about
this many times and i think you can
preach unlimited sermons
on the first verse now faith is the
substance of things hoped for
the evidence of things not
seen and i've always said that this is
the most
ridiculous verse in the bible
if you take it at face value
but it is the most important verse in
the bible because verse 6
says without faith it is impossible to
please him
so if faith is the substance of things
hoped for and the evidence of things
not seen then faith
is something that by definition
is not based on what you see no it's
based on what you believe
i always use the example of a
court of justice
and the judge calls the witness to the
front and says
please tell us what you saw in this case
give us your witness and the witness
says
uh your honor this is what i did not see
then what would the judge say sorry
excuse me what are you doing here you're
wasting the court's time right
and how can something that you hope
for have substance
you cannot hope for something and that
has
substance at the same time because
substance
implies that the thing that you are
hoping for is really there is a reality
you cannot hope to be driving a ferrari
and then have the substance at the same
time you cannot climb into the hope and
put your foot down and feel the
difference right correct
no so faith is something that is based
on something
that you know will happen but it has not
happened yet
didn't you also say that once
we are in heaven you won't need faith
anymore because
got the substance so faith is the
substance of things hoped for i hope for
eternal life
and this hope must be so real that it
actually has substance for you
it must be tangible you must be living
in that hope already
and how do you attain to this hope by
faith
and where do you get it from christ
you have to appropriate his
righteousness and by faith you must
assume that he has
imparted it and imputed to it
and your friends will have to say what
happened to you you totally changed i
don't know you anymore
there must be a change the
transformation without the
transformation there's no
evidence at all that you know christ
right
for by it the elders obtained a good
report
through faith we understand that the
worlds were framed by the word of god
so that things which are seen were not
made
of things which do appear in other words
ex nilia he spoke and it stood fast
do you believe that yes well the
scientific world has to believe it
because the scientific world says the
big bang
came out of nothing came out of nothing
so they believe that
and they ridicule those that believe
what the bible says when their
own premise is as ridiculous actually
also a faith
it's a faith it's not science not at all
and they're trying to peddle it as
science in fact i have no problem with
science
but i have a problem with the philosophy
of science
by faith abel offered unto god a more
excellent sacrifice than cain and this
is what this question pertains to
they've got adam in there they've got
even they've got cain and abel in there
and the bible clearly tells us that the
sacrifice of
abel was more excellent than the
cain why because of his heart and
obedience
and he was appropriating a righteousness
which was
outside of himself he said the lamb
which i am
offering is my substitute
righteousness by faith he didn't
rely on himself he relied
on an external source exactly
and he was saved by the blood of that
lamb and what it can bring
the works of his hands the works of his
hands
and which one was more excellent abel's
was the correct one
okay now in the world today do we have
these two religious systems side by side
yes and did you know
that only protestantism
only protestantism which is a fraction
of the world's religions a tiny little
fraction even within christianity it is
a fraction
appropriates the righteousness of christ
as abel did
and the rest of the world
have a sacrifice of works yes
which is a very sad thing right yes
by faith enoch was translated that he
should not see death
and was not found because god had
translated him
for before his translation he had this
testimony that
he pleased god so here you have the
whole question
of death and resurrection
which is also negated by the world today
they say that when you die you go
directly to heaven
but here it clearly states
that enoch was translated alive
to heaven everybody else dies
and has to wait till the resurrection
the world doesn't believe that
so does it have the faith of jesus nope
no you have to believe what the bible
says in order to appropriate this faith
because without faith it is impossible
to please him
for he that comes to god must believe
that he is
and that he is a rewarder of them that
diligently seek him
righteousness by faith is the heart
of salvation and
even within the ranks of believers
you have the battle between the way of
cain
and the way of abel it will rage until
the final moments of earth's history
righteousness by faith is the heart of
the third angel's message
by faith noah we don't even have to go
further than that
he built an ark right correct does the
world believe that today
no no do they have faith so without
faith it is impossible to please him
do they please god by their evolutionary
ideas
and the denial of the universal flood no
no and then this verse that you were
referring to
by faith abraham when he was called to
go
out into a place which he should after
receive for inheritance
obeyed and he went out not knowing
whether he went
so what did he do with his faith he
acted upon it
and obeyed and did he receive the
promise there and then
no no he was a stranger and he sergeant
among strangers exactly
and even when it came to a burial place
did he did he receive it as a gift or
did he buy it he had to buy it
he bought it was offered to him as a
gift
but he bought it he bought it so
none of these had received the promise
and we can carry on and say by faith
he's sergeant in a land of promise as in
a strange country
dwelling in tabernacles with isaac and
jacob the heirs with him of the same
promise not of the substance
but by faith they had the substance even
though they
didn't actually feel it for he looked
for a city and here's another point
he looked for a city which had
foundations
whose builder and maker is gone
now is there a city in heaven
where god is the architect and the
builder
yes is this according to the bible yes
does the book of revelation tell us that
there will be a new jerusalem which will
come
down from heaven dressed like a bride
correct the city of god do people
believe that
no they want an earthly kingdom
they want an earthly kingdom but we want
a heavenly kingdom right
so let's go back to that that verse in
john chapter 14. i mean we've read it so
many times it's unbelievable
but this is the heart of the matter
and we must know this one of by heart
let not your hearts be troubled you
believe
now there's that little word right
in god believe also in me in my father's
house so many
mansions if it were not so i would have
told you i go to prepare
a place for you is this a real place or
is this a ghostly place no
it's a real place whose maker and
builder is god is god and if i go and
prepare a place for you
i will come again and receive you unto
myself that where i
am there ye may be also and whether i go
ye no and the way
ye know what is the way the truth and
the life
jesus he is the way the truth and the
life
so righteousness by faith is the only
way
to appropriate salvation and to be
heirs of the promise
and out of your faith your obedience
flows one last verse
while it springs to mind go to isaiah
chapter 58
have you got it yes and let's go to
verse 13.
and read verse 13 and 14 the last two
verses of isaiah
58 if thou turn
away thy foot from the sabbath
from doing thy pleasure on my
holy day and called the sabbath a
delight
the holy of the lord honorable and shalt
honor him not doing thine own ways nor
finding thine own pleasure nor speaking
thine
own words then
that's a very important word then after
all these things shalt i delight thyself
in the lord
and i will cause thee to ride
upon the high places of the earth and
feed thee with the heritage of
jacob thy father for the mouth of the
lord has
spoken it what is the heritage of jacob
eternal life that is the heritage of
jacob
and the promise was that he would
inherit
canaan and that was a typical canaan
and here we're referring of course to
the anti-typical
canaan so another question
does the sabbath play a pivotal role
in the faith question yes
let's just let's just recap did the
world
or does the world believe in the story
of
noah as told in the bible no no no we
actually saw it's a conspiracy
correct so do they believe in the
creation account
that's the very first statement in the
book of hebrews chapter 11
that the world was framed right you have
to believe that what's the symbol of
that
the sabbath so if you keep the sabbath
is that works or is that an
acknowledgement of a completed work that
christ has already performed in creation
and redemption exactly
it's part of righteousness by faith you
cannot separate it
you cannot separate it so may god give
us wisdom
as we separate salvation by works
from salvation by faith and as we look
at the sabbath as the great memorial of
your faith
in that creation and that redemption
may god give us wisdom let's pray
heavenly father
your book is so full
of wisdom that needs to be tapped
and i pray that the holy spirit may
enlighten
our minds and minds of readers
that they may understand the depth and
the length and the breadth
of your word which is unto salvation
this is my prayer in jesus name amen
amen
thank you for watching this video to
subscribe to our channel
click here to get notifications click on
the bell
to watch the next video click here
thank you and we'll see you again